right now you have kids on campus just
this week Princeton black lives matter
students listed their demands black only
cultural spaces in the name of equality
they're demanding segregation for the
first time since the civil rights in the
United States you have people literally
demanding segregated spaces no word yet
as to whether they want black and white
drinking fountains and if white people
should be at the back of the bus 2015
can be seen definitively as the year
liberalism's chickens came home to roost
well what do I mean by that let's think
about this for a second we've been told
how great Barack Obama's been for
national security because Osama bin
Laden was killed been told how great the
economy is because unemployment is an
all-time low we've been told how
tolerant and how much of a uniter Barack
Obama would be in the United States he
would cause healing to take place right
now our economy is probably the one of
the worst ever
now people say unemployment will
actually job participation is at an
all-time low
since October 1977 we've never had fewer
people working 62 percent of Americans
are participating in the job force right
now so you can say unemployment is lower
that's because people aren't looking for
jobs they're not even considered a part
of the job force many of them are on the
government teat which is what liberals
want anyways that's how leftists want
society to function they want the
welfare state and that's funny he'll say
we will first it that's what Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton say when you
watch the Democratic debates I know they
put them on a late Saturday night
running opposite a UFC event and I think
the next one is on Super Bowl Sunday
opposite the Super Bowl on Telemundo
they don't want you to see the debates
they put them at the worst times where
no one watches them why because I know
they say crazy stuff but they don't want
the media to catch up on it so they use
the word welfare say that's what left us
want we have the lowest job
participation rate right now than ever
that's bad for the economy that's really
bad if you people aren't working that's
bad for the economy and most of the jobs
that were created obviously that they
claim they've created are simply
government jobs which are of course not
real jobs they're taking the money from
you to create busywork
they're just creating busy work but that
sounds great doesn't it come work for
the government you get free money yeah
but who's giving you that money money
money who do you trust me I'm giving
away free money yeah exactly
national security since basically
abandoning Iraq a vacuum was created
unstable Middle East Barack Obama said
Isis was contained actually global
terrorism has increased a whopping 80
percent and Isis is more powerful than
ever
we now have Syrian refugees wanting to
come in several have been caught with
fake passports trying to get in refugees
have been caught as terrorists in the
Paris attacks some from Belgium Boston
bomber bombers terrorists so national
security is at an all-time low we have a
lowest job participation rate we have
Isis and global terrorism more prevalent
and powerful than ever and then of
course the first black president the
racial divide was going to be bridge
there was going to be some healing right
right now you have people who believe
that racial tensions are worse than ever
at an all-time high right now you have
kids on campus just this week
Princeton black lives matter students
listed their demands black only cultural
spaces in the name of equality they're
demanding segregation for the first time
since the civil rights in the United
States you have people literally
demanding segregated spaces no word yet
as to whether they want black and white
drinking fountains and if white people
should be at the back of the bus but
they do want black only spaces so we're
more racist for fake reasons when Barack
Obama says my son would look like
Trayvon when we come out and say these
students really their voices need to be
heard and you give them legitimacy when
they're absolute and total brats who've
liked many of them have gotten into
college because of affirmative action
who are there who think that the the
Dean of Yale or president of Yale they
told them his job was to create a safe
space for people to create a home his
job wasn't to educate I mean the Yale
Princeton
Mitsu
black lives matter Baltimore by the way
Baltimore most violent year in
Baltimore's history most violent
homicide rate ever ever in their history
so we've got the economy lowest job
participation rate since 1977
national security do you really think
we're safer but Osama bin Laden's dead
great now we've got Isis the most brutal
people Tim Kennedy was talking about
this the most brutal people we've had to
deal with awful awful people and they're
more powerful than ever global terrorism
80% higher healing bridging reaching
across the aisle this has been the most
partisan president in history and of
course United States is more racially
divided then it's ever been in my
lifetime you have black LaShawn King
DeRay saying this is worse at least as
bad if not worse than the civil rights
era so 2015 is the year the economy went
to crap national security ceased to be
and all of a sudden all Americans all
white Americans became more racist than
ever and needed to be reprimanded and
need needed to be held accountable in
2015
here's the point you can only push that
off for so long you can only put in so
many stimulus packages and create so
many fake government jobs until you
start looking at the the job
participation rate you can only start
being politically correct and and
kicking the terrorism fighting can down
the road until that comes back to bite
you you can only start saying Trayvon
would be my son or talk about police
brutality or say that we need to give
these people enough space to destroy in
Baltimore and cater to them until you
see the worst homicide rate in the
country ever until you see campuses in
complete and total upheaval and racial
tensions worse than ever you can only do
that for so long you can only pass the
same thing with Social Security
eventually you can only pass that tab
down for so long well guess what it's
2015 you think this is a great year for
America you think this is progress
you think we're more United we're safer
and have a stronger economy than ever if
you do go ahead tweet me at s Crowder
I don't know I think anyone with even a
a semblance of logic would say 2015
that's a rough year that's a crazy it's
craziest year of news in my life you
know it's a year left isms chickens came
home to roost the bills here okay if you
like this video I'm going to level with
you here you can subscribe by clicking
my face or the button above or you can
close this window and not subscribe it
is entirely your prerogative all I am
doing is requesting that you subscribe
because we work really hard on these
videos and they take a lot of time but
you don't have to also there's a pipe
bomb in your car I would recommend you
subscribe